[MUSIC]
SPEAKER: Some of the world's greatest
athletes make vast amounts of money.
The soccer star Cristiano
Ronaldo makes $80 million a year,
counting salary and endorsements.
Basketball great LeBron
James makes $72 million.
Tiger Woods, the golfer,
earns $61 million in a year.
And tennis star Roger
Federer makes $56 million.
Some people argue that rich
people like these sport stars
should be taxed to help the poor.
Others argue that taxation
for redistribution is unjust.
They say it is admirable for rich people
voluntarily to help people in need
but wrong for the state
to force them to do so.
What do you think?
Is it just or unjust for the state
to tax the rich to help the poor?
[MUSIC]